- So you two bonded when you got
to Atlanta to film the movie, right?
- We did. We immediately got coffee
before we ever filmed,
because, you know, we
had never met outside
of the chemistry read.
- Yeah.
- But even after the chemistry read,
I think it was so clear.
The call that we came
after the chemistry read
from Jama was like, so it's cute, right?
I was right. Yeah, Yeah Okay.
We're on the same page, cool, cool
(laughter)
And we were in Atlanta
and then we I was like, let's grab coffee.
- Yeah
- We hung out for two, three, four hours.
Walked around, found an art commune.
- Yeah, we just stumbled
across this art commune and
in like this railroad area,
and it was such a random moment.
We were like silent for
like two minutes walking
just looking at everything.
And then Noah just turns
to me and he's like,
Who let us be superheroes?
(laughter)
And then we just started
dying and that was kind of
like the start of just this
beautiful like relationship
and just like friendship,
you know, with Noah.
Couldn't be more thankful for it.
- Yeah.
(applause)